[Musique]
mais déjà la vie site où quand et
astucieux belle
[Musique]
et à jouer il s'est mis debout noir un
ami
[Musique]
bonjour l hommiste heures tout comme
your eyes and very well bondi de suis
content de te voir tu vois je je me
rends tourner un film là dans la forêt
oui je me demandais ce que cette
excellente gestion des jeux fait une
mise en scène
ah bon je voulais voir si tu pourrais me
passer une petite audition ainsi je peux
te prendre oui ça je pense oui
certainement oui voici un tout à l'heure
après le après l'expérience
oui d'accord d'accord alors excédé rien
tu vois ce que j'ai amené là aussi pour
ton expérience
oui je vois que nous avons bouteille un
morceau de bois sera bien boire appuyé
une bouteille et une ombrelle
c'est ce que je viens de dire oui mais
je le montre et pourquoi tu me singes on
recoupe fait très attention à ce que tu
dis simplement je montrais à nos amis le
détail des opérations à la alors comment
peux tu faire tenir ici là nous il est
visible les fruits comment peux tu faire
tenir la bouteille en équilibre sur le
petit bout de bois sur le bâton sur le
bâton larry oui la bouteille
elle doit tenir en équilibre c'est pas
possible
mais as tu vois mais nous est ici faut
utiliser le l'ombrelle sûrement voilà
alors si brive et astucieux tâche de
trouver le moyen de te servir du
parapluie pour que tous tiennent pour
que toutes les nanas à attend alors tant
pis si c'est ça ça tu ballan est atteint
si j'essayais un système puis ça y est
on attend c'est peu commode ça ça fait
contrepoids tu vois olala c'est bien
beau la regardez moi ça c'est magnifique
1 ah oui ça y est c'est réussi tu vois
mais on doit tout de même là dedans un
peu denses expérience qui m'a fait
plaisir de te montrer mais c'est de la
mise en vente amusant tout le monde peut
le faire
oh oui tout le monde absolument si on a
bien sûr la braderie le parapluie ne
connaissait pas un nom il ya fabien m'en
aller maintenant on va se promener
bonne idée voyons mot-à-mot
chroniquement une promenade
c'est aussi un exercice de réflexion le
mot à mot
car vous utiliserez les cartons que nous
allons découvrir ensemble qui représente
des choses des animaux etc et qui forme
à chaque fois une syllabe avec ses
syllabes
nous essaierons de fabriquer des mots
alors vous jouez en même temps que nous
bien entendu en même temps que rapide
aux pouces conçu et thuc encore à givet
chevelu au col trouvait a été très fort
l'autre jour rapidos très très fort et
rapide hausse oui ce qu'il ya tout
qu'encore y est tout le temps on veut le
voir tout prendre tout dire i say to
meet et 4 décembre
alors voici un véhicule que l'on appelle
un vent vn et qui sert à transporter les
chevaux bon ça à faire le cheval en
attendant non je compterai cheval ça
c'est une ans l'ancien oui pas à ce sont
des des côtes des côtes oui aux deux
pays
non moi des côtes de veau non maintenant
enfin ça c'est quoi ça tu ne parles le
bal
voilà et enfin sa hausse et un rond
oui parfaitement c'est un roman ou alors
soit vous êtes pratiquement rien mon
déjà oui toi et tu veux que je te dise
vas-y balle ans
ah oui oui bien joué oui parfaitement
bâle ans ah oui ça c'est ça bravo tu
vois là pour une fois je reconnais c'est
bien joué à les balances bobic avec les
eaux
je suis en train de regarder mais avec
les 3 cartons qui reste on peut pas
faire grand chose nous nous nous venons
allégeant reprendre première chose qu'on
continue à leur sort on sort une autre
carte mais un un vent fait qu'est-ce que
je sois un rond invs en rond un auvent
d'affaires forte et du sort une car les
encore une année un héron
l'empereur romain enfin on continue on
continue bon alors à revoilà le bout de
la ligne le fameux mot spécial lotion
sci oen a aussi reçu longuement oui très
bien
qu'est ce que tu dis toi j'ai encore un
mot quoi c'est encore moins un parent
dont j'ai encore un mot pour possible en
forme aujourd'hui
bah oui qu'est-ce que tu as trouvé ben
je vais te dire j'ai trouvé un vent
si on prend voilà bien joué un vent et
si oui à huy ah oui ça c'est bien joué
parfait alors on va l'écrire un vent
sion aujourd'hui dix ans pour
reconnaître aujourd'hui tu es très
enfants c'est moi qui va tirer le lait
truites pour récompenser nous une petite
fille ou un petit garçon alors bonjour
tank encore tant que je choisis au
hasard une pub tu veux ça j'ai failli la
vallée en bas non ça c'est pas
raisonnable c'est une lettre qui vient
de francs que fromont qui habite rue
lavoisier 7 à créteil et franck nous a
fait plein de petits dessins charmant
voyez y a des il ya des petites
querelles et à de petites choses c'est
très très mignon francs que from on a
gagné 1,10 que de la chanson des quatre
amis est ce que vous êtes d'accord
on se réunit à tort oui oui on est
d'accord vous font un conseil
d'administration pas toujours
voilà ce disque elle sera envoyée très
bientôt bien eh ben je crois que c'est à
douai j'y vais encore ah bah oui au
tableau est ce que tu te rends compte du
sport que vous m'avez fait beaucoup de
bien fabre entre tous contents et toi je
n'arrête pas et oui je vais me faire des
mollets de coureur cycliste ça parce que
tu ferais sans nous alors je me demande
je me demande
bon alors allons-y à nous deux we pray
oui ce sont près alors un mot en huile
est remis lettres en huile est méfie toi
or je vais méfier on commence par quelle
lettre on commence par un n 1 mène oui à
la presse alors les six petits traits
comme d'habitude qui remplace les
lettres mans comment la 1 2 3 4 5 6
la ligne en l'air as ou suzanne c'est un
pluriel alors oui on voit je me méfie
avec toi comme tu n'as aucune notion de
l'orthographe
alors c'est un moyen de transport et les
moyens de transport en tout genre parce
que je route et abris sûrs où seront
bien sûr riche oui c'est un moyen est ce
que ce sera un moyen de transport en
commun
exactement où dans les villes alors
sport dans les villes rêvées louis même
en dehors des villes dans la banlieue
partout dans la série fairy comme du
toucan avec un ennemi pour commencer un
petit je te donne une d'une lettre oui
parce que je ne vois pas ne vois pas non
dans alors donne la troisième lettre a
eu un transport en commun ont eu à la
wii qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être que
ça mince alors ou quand on est déjà
presque trouvé ce à quoi tu sais tu pas
le nautilus nom lotus est un sous marin
qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être que ça
avec un n 1 y est un moyen de transport
c'est par le métro attend hall alors
quoi qu'est ce qu'il ya aulas autobus un
autobus un autobus et brille quand tu as
fait la liaison et tu crois que la
première lettre cette âme n est bon et
ben dis-donc autobus bon ouvre
malheureux olalala autobus puis didier
notheaux bus être là dans ce but sans
thorgan l'autobus autobus à non
évidemment aulas comme automobile alors
voilà une automobile mais par de
l'automobile
vraiment ohlala hamel désolé enfin là
bas je vais au coin que c'est puni tout
cas on va aller voir bel ben oui je
crois que ça vous revient oublions ça
aux îles loyauté à la patrie ce cas je
l'avais quoi
music bêta côtoient oui tout est allé si
vite joué avec moi je suis pas alors je
vais te raconter l'histoire d'une
chanson à l'aide de certains mots
inachevé et du complet de ces mots par
des notes de musique que tu places sur
la portée musicale d'accord et à la fin
il y aura une petite surprise
bon voilà alors c'est une chanson
moderne que je vais te raconter
aujourd'hui une chanson dédiée aux
petits oiseaux qui vivent 100 kg oui
c'est ce réseau qui hélas sont une cage
pour tout missile a pour domicile
domicile de luiz mais tu sais qu'ils
sont toujours très bien soigné ce petit
oiseau ça oui on les nourrit on les
protège comme s'il faisait partie de la
une
mia famille parfait voilà on s'arrange
pour l'heure pour que leur cage soit
toujours bien propre bien vu bien laver
viala là j'ai vu il y en a même qui leur
fournissent des tas d'accessoires des
balançoires enfin tout une installation
lation nationale a bien sûr ils sont là
dedans comme dans un par balle à ce
n'était pas tant pas l'allemand tu sais
malgré tout ils sont prisonniers
et ça c'est pas tellement drôle moi je
les comprends à leur place je ferais une
marque 10 l'a dit oui alors je voudrais
de mode deux enfants de faire quelque
chose en leur nom leur faveur
voilà phase et ce quelque chose consiste
à ouvrir la porte de leur cage pour
qu'il puisse aller se promener se bat à
des labels parfait oui et tu verras ça
leur fait sa une nouveau maire rend
aussi rond ciron si l'on me cimon vas-y
maintenant pénates
alors attendez la chanson va faire ça
tranquillement tu vas voir
j'ai vu je vais apporter
les petits matches
alors on chante ensemble à la main qu'on
doit donner la nature
c'est là la sq de lier cette chanson we
de pierre perret ouvrez la cage aux
oiseaux y voilà bon ben maintenant on va
ouvrir ou plutôt terminé notre petite
émission
j'arrive en chantant alors tu comprends
tu venu de paris mon clan 17,4 à son
déjà papa famille ducale où la gironde
qui fera que la vie m'a fait désirer
choc fait des choses mais comme juni pas
de mine war il faudra faire attention
les quatre amis quand ils ont réussi
mais y'a qu'ça me sens heureux d'arisem
avis
oui
[Musique]
jamie pour jouer aujourd'hui
il dit vouloir devenir un ami
[Musique]